قضيه العنصريه ضد فينيسيوس تتفاقم وتتحول
لازمه دوليه
وفطيحه خيانه وابتزاز وحنه العروس واغنيه
خاصه للعريس تحضيرات زفاف ولعهد الاردن
تجتاح المنصات عربيا اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
امس ناولنا موضوع العنصريه لوجه اللاعب
البرازيلي فينيسيوس خلال مباراه فريق ريال
مدريد مع فالنسيا ضمن الدوري الاسباني
واليوم صارت في المزيد من التطورات
فالازمه تحولت لازمه دوليه وتطورت اكثر
واكثر وشفنا فيها دول بترد ورئيس بيهاجم
ونوادي بتدعم فعلى المستوى الرسمي في
البرازيل كان في تحركات اولها كان من
الرئيس البرازيلي لولدي سيلفا اللي اعلن
دعمه وتضامنه مع فينيسيوس
النوم
اما وزاره الخارجيه البرازيليه فاستدعت
السفير الاسباني عشان تحقق في اليسار مع
فينيسيوس وكنوع من التضامن اختتمت
البرازيل يومها اللي اعلنت فيه تضامنها مع
فينيسيوس باطفاء ضوء تمثال المسيح
الايقوني في ريو دينيرو لمده ساعه كامله
وفي اسبانيا لقب فينيسيوس دعم كمان فنشر
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الاسباني بيدرسون
تغريديجل فيها انه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
تسامح مع العنصريه في كره القدم ومجلس
الرياضه الاسباني اصدر بيان جير في انه
راح يراجع او يرجع يشوف لقطات من المباراه
لاستدعاء اي شخص من مرتكبي الواقعه للمثول
امام الادعاءات هذه التطورات على المستوى
الرسمي والسياسي اما المستوى الرياضي فكان
في سيل من الادانات للي صار مع فينيسيوس
ونبدا من رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
اللي اعلن دعمه لفينيسيوس وقال انه الف
يفا بتوقف جنب كل لاعب يتعرض لنفس الموقف
ونشر خطوات عمليه للتخلص من هذه الظاهره
خلال مباريات كره القدم اما رئيس الاتحاد
الاسباني لويس روباليس اعترف انه كره
القدم الاسبانيه بتعاني من مشكله العنصريه
واعلنت دعم لفينيسيوس
مره
وعلى فكره هو ما اكتفى بس بدعم فينيسيوس
لا كمان فاجا الكل بطلبه من رئيس الاتحاد
البرازيلي لكره القدم انه يتجاهل السلوك
غير المسؤول لرئيس الدوري الاسباني خفير
تيباس لمن ارد على فينيسيوس على تويتر
ووصف اللي عمله بالتباهي على الشبكات
الاجتماعيه طبعا رئيس رابطه الدوري
الاسباني كان رد على فينيسيوس على تويتر
وقال له انه الرابطه بتعمل اللازم ضد
العنصريه ولكن الرابطه كانت اعلنت مؤخرا
انها فتحت تحقيق في الواقعه ومحاسبه
المتورطين فيها انادي فالنسيا من اعلن
دعمه لفينيسيوس اللي من وقت الحانته واسمه
ضمن حمله التضامن ودعم واسعه من نجوم
ورياضيين وانديه
اما بخصوص البيت الداخلي لنادي ريال مدريد
اللي فينيسيوس من ضمن لاعبي فكان لرئيسه
فلورنتينو بيريز لقاء مع فينيسيوسفي مقر
الفريق الملكي واظهر خلاله دعم او دعم
ريال مدريد الكامل ليفينيسيوس اما النادي
فيكنلو بيان رسمي شكر في كل اللي وقف الى
جانب اللاعب من شخصيات رسميه وغير رسميه
واعرب عن امتنان لكل من تضامن مع فينيسيوس
من زملائه وقال انهم تفاجئوا بتصريحات
رئيس الاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم وانه ما
اخذ الاجراءات اللازمه ضد اللي صار وانه
هذا الموقف خلى فينيسيوس عاجز امام الحكام
اتابع انه بيامل للتوصل لاجراءات حازمه
وفوريه للقضاء على العنصريه وحقيقا وحقيقه
طبعا يعني التطورات حول القضيه بتتسارع
كثير وملحقين على العناوين والاخبار اللي
بتيجي ومن ساعه بس صار في تطورات كثيره
منها انه الشرطه الاسبانيه يحتجزت سبعه
على علاقه باساءات عنصريه ضد فينيسيوس 3
في فالنسيا واربعه في مدريد وكمان طلع
المدير الفني لنادي ريال مدريد كارلو
انشيلوتوغال انه لازم يكون في تصدي
للعنصريه او انه هذه مباراه مو حرب
ضحيه وماله ذنبه انه ما بيقدر يتدرب لانه
حزين بسبب اللي صار واكد انه ما رح يغادر
نادي ريال مدريد لانه بيحب النادي وبحب
بلده ومن التطورات اللافته كمان خلال
الساعات الماضيه انه شركه بومه اللي هي
راعي فريق فالنسيان قدمت كل دعمها
لفينيسيوس وحتى بنك السانتادير او
الاسباني الراعي للدوري الاسباني اعلن
دعمه لفينيسيوس ورفضه للتحيز العنصري
وحقيقه اللي صار مع فينيسيوس واللي تكلم
فيها عن العنصريه اللي بيواجهها بالدوري
الاسباني اضاء على تعليقات جالسين بنسمعها
كثير على المنصات وتحديدا في الفتره
الاخيره وخصوصا من متابعي الكره اللي
بيلوموا على اللي بيصير تحديدا في الكره
الاوروبيه او بيقولوا انه العنصريه اللي
بتصير فيها ما بنشوفها في اي مكان ثاني
هذا غير الانتقادات للفيفا والاتحاد
الاوروبي اللي الناس شايفه انهم ما
بيعملوا اللازم لوقت هذه الظاهره تماما
على الاقل يعني في الملاعب وخلال
المباريات لو مو قادرين مثلا يقضوا عليها
تماما في الشوارع وعلى المنصات طيب خلينا
نناقش هذا الموضوع معنا من القاهره
الاعلامي والمحل الرياضي
اسر حسين خليل نناقش معك الموضوع اليوم
بالتفصيل اهلا فيك معانا يا اسر طيب هل
بتتفق مع وجهه النظر اللي بتقول انه
الدوري الاسباني بالتحديد والدوري
الاوروبي عموما الدوريات الاوروبيه هي
الاكثر عنصريه
اهلا بك يا ساره وسعيد اللي معك مع جمهورك
المحترم بالطبع بعتقد ان انا يعني بوافق
على جزء كبير من اللي بيتقال ان الدوري
الاسباني من اكثر الدوريات عنصريه لانه
حتى على مستوى الخمس دوريات الكبرى اللي
هي بتمثل اوروبا او اللي احنا عارفينها
خمس دولارات الكبرى واعتقد ان اسبانيا
يمكن وايطاليا اقلهم في التعامل مع
العنصريه وعندنا موقع مهمه جدا يا ساره
يمكن في الاسابيع الماضيه كانت في الدوري
الايطالي روميل لوكاكو اللاعب البلجيكي
وهو اسمر البشره كما فينيسيوس تماما وكان
جمهور يوفنتوس بيشتمه او بيقول عليه هتاف
جمعي عنصري واللعب احتفل بتسجيل ضربه جزاء
في ملعب يوفنتوس بانه بس اشار له علامه
الصمت وبالتالي تم طرده بالظبط طرد الضحيه
او معاقبه الضحيه طرده من اللقاء ومنع
جمهور او جزء من مدرج يوفنتوس انه يحضر
مباراه وبعد كده الاتحاد الايطالي يقرر او
يعني الرجوع في القرار وعدم منع الجمهور
من حضور اللقاء هي نفس الفكره في مساله
فينيسيوس ومساله فالنسيا ومساله الدوري
الاسبانيه فكره من امن العقاب الحقيقه ناس
بتتكلم على طب نعمل ايه في دول برضو فيها
جزء كبير من العنصريه ولكن سبقت اسبانيا
بكتير منهم انجلترا منجلترا خلال العامين
الماضيين صدر اول حكم تجاه مشجع بيستخدم
حتى مش حتى في هتاف جامعه الاستاد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي في عنصريه واتحبس اسود
وهو كان عنده 50 عام حكومه سوري عقوبه حبس
ثمان اسابيع وتغريمه 500 استرليني وكان
احد افراد جمهور ويستش وانهيتافات عنصريه
في الملعب تم ايجاده من خلال الكاميرات
وكذلك انما النهارده طبعا رد الفعل
النهارده افضل بكثير من رد الفعل بالامس
وطبعا تصريحات المستفزه جدا لفينيسيوس
بعتقد زي ما حضرتك تفضلت في التقرير لويس
روبياله الرئيس الاتحاد ده حاول يلم
الموضوع من حتى فكره البي ار او الدعايه
العامه المناسبه
للدوري الاسباني بانه يقول انه لا في
مشكله عنصريه والهتاف الجمعي ده بيدين
فالنسيا وبيدين النادي بالذاته طبعا في
الاشاره الملعب فالنسي اللي حصلت فيه الح
ادثه الحاجه التانيه طبعا من المستجدات
ليش تعتقد انه الموضوع هذه المره تحديدا
وصل لهذه الدرجه يعني شفنا انه رئيس
الدوله تحدث يعني كثير ناس اسماء كبيره
تحدثت
لانه صار الموضوع بيستمر وما فيش حل جذري
ليه ناس بتتكلم بمنتهى سذاجه او براءه
دايما يعني الفاعل او او العمل الجريمه
الكراهيه دي بانه نعمل ايه لا في حاجات
كتير قوي تعمله بعتقد انه نجاح الحمله هذه
المره هو انه طبعا لولا ده سيلفر رئيس
البرازيل استخدم اهم منبر وهو الوجود في
مجموعه السبع في الجي 7 في هيروشيما
واتكلم مدافع عن لاعب او مواطن عنده
برازيلي بيتعرض لعنصريه تامه الكلام لازم
يكون على
عقوبه بخصم النقاط عقوبه من حرمان الجمهور
من الحضور اللي بيعمل الفعل العنصري ده
وهو مشجع لنادي ساره اهم حاجه تفرق معاه
هو النادي لو حرمته من الحضور او حرمت
الجمهور من من المدرج او حرمت النادي من
جمهور هنا
الحسن ناس كثير كمان خلينا يعني نعطي وجهه
النظر الاخرى ناس كثير جالسين بيقولوا انه
يعني معليش مع هذه كره قدم وفيها تعليقات
من هذا النوع وياما اللعيبه في الملاعب
بيسمعوا كلمات مش ضروري حتى عنصريه كلمات
من نوع اخرى شتائم وما الى ذلك وانه مثلا
دائما بيذكروا ح ادثه اللي هي لاعب
برشلونه من لمن رامولو موزه في الملعب فهو
مسكها ووقف واكلها وكمل لعب يعني فبيقولوا
انه يعني خلاص انه شويه ربوا جلد اسمك
يعني
لا طبعا ده طبعا كلام في اتجاه سلبي جدا
في اتجاه قبول امور لا يمكن تكون مقبوله
في القرن الحادي والعشرين لا يمكن ابدا
تقبل العنصريه باي شكل من اشكال سواء
عنصريه بلون البشره سواء عنصريه ضد مثلا
الجنس تجاه مثلا لاعبات كره القدم تجاه اي
شيء لابد من عدم قبوله كمان الكلام على هل
حقيقي هل هل هل هل في الموقف اللي حصل ده
في حد دفع الثمن حتى الان بشكل رسمي
الضحيه وهو فينيسيوس تعرض للطرد قرار
مناسب جدا النهارده من اتحاد الاسباني
بانه انه اعفى سته من الحكام اللي موجودين
في غرفه الفار يا ساره من التحكيم وراحلهم
عن التحكيم في الدوري الاسباني لكن في
النهايه السؤال هل هيرفع الطرد اللي اخذه
فينيسيوس بشكل ظالم والحقيقه الجاني
الحقيقه
وقرار كمان اتحاد الحكام في اسبانيا راجع
لانه لم يقدم او كان في تلاعب باللقطات في
غرفه الفار بانه ارسلوا اللقطات غير
الصحيحه للحكم ريكاردو بانه دافنيسيوس هو
اللي زق اللاعب وفي الحقيقه ان اللاعب هو
ان كان تم بخنقه في لقطات ثابته فالتلاعب
باللقطات في غرفه الفار ادى الى اعفاء سته
من الحكام الفار في المباراه وعلى راسهم
طبعا اللي كان مسؤول عن غرفه الفار
فبالتالي ده قرار مهم ولكن هل هترفع عقوبه
الطرد عن اللاعب اللي هو في الاساس هو
الضحيه على العموم احنا لانه واضح انه
الموضوع يعني بيتطور وواضح انه خلص
اللعيبه ويمكن الفرق كمان خلاص ملوا من
هذا الموضوع فنحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا
حتى كمان
الرياضي اسر حسين طبعا اكيد حتى المشجعين
طبعا
للملياردير الامريكي مؤسس شركه مايكروسوفت
حصه من اخبارنا اليوم وهذه الاخبار حقيقه
صادمه ومؤسر ابدا
اللي كانت سنوات
ال 27 من الزواج بالطلاق من زوجته ميلاندا
يعني جيت بيواجه فضيحه وورطه نقدر
نعانونها بفضيحه خيانه وابتزاز ففي تقرير
كشفت عنه
كان على علاقه وهو متزوج مع الرياضيات
الروسيه
ميلانوفا اللي تعرف عليها في 2010 ومو بس
كده الصادم انه تعرض لابتزاز بيخص علاقته
بالفتاه الروسيه وللتهديد بكشف هذه
العلاقه من شخص بالتاكيد ما في احد يتمنى
انه يرتبط اسمه فيه وهو رجل الاعمال راحل
جفري ابستين اللي حاطط فيه مصائب وفضائح
الدنيا كلها من تحرج تجاره بشر وابتزاز
وغيرها وكان القبض عليه ومات في السجن
بظروف غامضه واللي اغلبها بيقول انه انتحر
اللي صار انه بعد عام 2008 وسمعته انهدمت
بسبب قضيه تحرش وبقاصر قرر يعمل صندوق
خيري بمليارات الدولارات علشان يجمل سمعته
ويعيد بنائها وكان بيلقيت من الاشخاص اللي
ضمن القائمه لكن ما قدر يقنع جيت بانه
يساهم في الصندوق وعلشان كده هددوا واللي
بيسال طب ايش دخل الفتاه الروسيه في لانه
بكل بساطه راحت لعند 2013 وعملت دوره
برمجه وما دفعت فلوس لانه اتكفل بتدريبها
بالكامل ولكن بعد ما عرفت بعلاقتها مع بيل
جيتس صار بيهدد بفتح العلاقه لو ما شارك
في الصندوق الخيري وهذا اللي صار لكن يعني
مو هو عايش وهو ميت
[موسيقى]
اهتمام كبير وتفاعل واسع بنشوفه في
الاخبار على المنصات مع قرب موعد زفاف ولي
عهد الاردن الامير حسين بن عبد الله
الثاني من السعوديه رجوى السيف وهاشتاق
نفرح بالحسين مالي المنصات داخل الاردن
وخارجها الزفاف الملكي اللي راح يتم يوم
الخميس اول من يونيو راح يكون في مراسم
ملكيه بدايه من عقد القران في قصر الزهران
اللي هو من اقدم قصور عمان وصار في قبل 30
سنه زفاف الملك عبد الله والملكه رانيا
وايامها كان الملك عبد الله امير بعد عقد
القران في قصر زهران في حفله ومادبه عشاء
في قصر الحسينيه وكان تم الاعلان عن حفل
يوم الاثنين في استاذ عمان الدولي ومجاني
للاردنيين للاحتفال بزفاف الامير والحفل
بمشاركه راغب علامه وتامر حسني واحمد سعد
وديانا كرزون وزين عوض وخلال الساعات
الماضيه اللي شاغل الناس هو
حنه رجوى ليقيمت في مضارب بني هاشم وكانت
الملكه رانيا نشرت لقطات من التحضير للحنه
والاكسسوارات والزينه فيها واللي واضح انه
اغلبها مشغوله يدويا وكلها بطابع تراثي
العروس رجوله لفتت الانظار في ليله الحنه
بالفستان ابيض مطرز بخيوط الذهب والحرير
من تصميم المصممه السعوديه هنيده الصيرفي
واللي حرصت في تفاصيله على المزج بين
الثقافه السعوديه والاردنيه وقالت انها
صممته ليحكي قصه الحب بين الامير والانسه
الرجوى وتكلمت المصممه عن كل المعاني
والرسائل الموجوده في الفستان والاكثار
يمكن للوهله الاولى ما بيشوفوها لكن لفتت
كمان الى بيت الشعر الظاهر في الفستان وهو
لابو قاسم الشابي اراك فتحلو لدى الحياه
اما فتحلو لدي الحياه اما الملكه رانيا
فطلت بفستان بالازرق من تصميم المصمم
اللبناني سعيد كبيسي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رجوه هي احلى رجاء مني لرب العالمين لحسين
اردنيه
[موسيقى]
يلا يا كريم
يا
[موسيقى]
الله غريب الصبايا وين وين
حسين هو فرحه الاولى ابن البكر شاب هاشمي
واعي وعارف انه هو منكم والكم وزي اي ام
انا من زمان بحلم اني اشوفه عريس حسين
ابنكم انتم اهله وهذا عرسكم واخيرا صار
عندي كنه
بس مش اي كنه ما شاء الله عليها رجوى يعني
جد غلاوتها من غلاوه ايمان وسلمى
عزه انا بعرف انا كنت بمحلك قبل شهرين
وبعرف انت كيف شعري بس بدي اطمنك انه رجوى
بعيوننا وبعيون حسين وهي بين اهلها وناسها
فاطمئني عليها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن يومين نشرت الملكه رانيا على حساباتها
اغنيه لولي العهد من غناء فرقه جماعه خير
الاردنيه الاغنيه للان جامعه 4 مليون
مشاهده وحقيقه مؤثره جدا سواء بكلامها او
باللقطات اللي في الفيديو خصوصا ظهور
الملك الراحل حسين فبتركم مع مقطع من
الاغنيه واعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في
امان الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
شعور جميل وصعب
من اجمل اللحظات كانت لما الولد الله
يرحمه حضن ابني حسين
[موسيقى]
يا ابوي مثل الحلم هالوقت غير غير عيوني
لاغلى
انت مع الظلم حد
ايامنا تكرج كرج يا ابويا انا يغلى ظنوا
مثل الثلج
تعبا
ك يا حزران اليوم شاهد عيان
ايش هذا على عرسان اكون
نيالك يا حزران ما انت شاهد زمان يوم اللي
كان طفل بيحب
لا تبك انا دبكه معاك وارقص خيلي فراخ
وادعي رب الكون
لا لا يا ابوي
الحلم هالوك مرقت غير عيوني
[موسيقى]